Для мене честь і приємність приймати президента Зеленського
у Білому домі, в Овальному кабінеті.
У період святкування 30-річчя Незалежності України
партнерство між нашими країнами стає міцнішим,
ніж будь-коли, і зміцнюватиметься ще.
Зустріч пройшла в "нормальній, продуктивній та не постійно сонячній атмосфері".
"Чоловіча розмова", - так Володимир Зеленський підсумував
свій офіційний візит до президента США Джо Байдена у Вашингтон.
Двогодинні перемови, спільне фото в Овальному кабінеті,
зустрічі з американськими урядовцями.
Про що саме Зеленський домовився у Вашингтоні?
Найбільш розтиражованим у ЗМІ підсумком зустрічі двох президентів
стала заява про відновлення стратегічного партнерства у галузі оборони
й надання Україні 60-ти-мільйонного пакету допомоги.
Він передбачає надання оборонної летальної зброї,
зокрема, бронебійних систем "Джавелін", а також нелетальної зброї.
Це дозволить Україні посилити захист від російської агресії, підкреслили у Вашингтоні.
Сторонам ще належить конкретизувати ці домовленості.
Цим опікуватиметься американський міністр оборони -
уже цієї осені Ллойд Остін приїде до Києва, де працюватиме над змістом
оборонних угод разом з українським колегою Андрієм Тараном.
Наразі відомо, що розрахований на п'ять років договір про партнерство
передбачає поглиблену співпрацю між оборонними відомствами України та США
у кібербезпеці, безпеці Чорноморського регіону та розвідки,
а також реформи оборонного сектору.
А ось конкретики щодо "Північного потоку-2" - значно менше.
Додаткових роз’яснень щодо угоди між США і Німеччиною щодо російського газогону
Вашингтон не надав. Обмежився заявою про те, що США і далі виступають
проти проєкту, який вважають загрозою для європейської енергетичної безпеки.
Крім того, Білий дім пообіцяв застосувати важелі енергетичної дипломатії.
У перекладі на повсякденну мову це означає, що збереження
транзитної ролі України та безперебійні поставки палива у Вашингтоні
відстежуватиме спеціально призначений для цього радник держсекретаря з енергетичної безпеки.
Амос Хохштайн має досвід запуску великих енергопроєктів
і навіть устиг попрацювати у наглядовій раді українського "Нафтогазу".
Володимир Зеленський, схоже, вважає проблему "Північного потоку" врегульованою -
він заявив, що отримав від Джо Байдена особисті гарантії щодо "Північного потоку-2".
Президент Байден особисто гарантує, що якщо з боку Російської Федерації
чи якщо з боку представників інших сторін "Північного потоку-2"
у разі його запрацювання, якщо з боку цих країн
будуть порушені якісь речі, які передбачають небезпечну ситуацію
через енергетичну енергетичні проблеми для України,
то Сполучені штати гарантують введення санкцій проти "Північного потоку-2".
А тим часом Україна і США домовились започаткували стратегічний
енергетичний та кліматичний діалог. У підписаних рамкових угодах
ідеться про реформування державного енергосектору України
та виконання кліматичних цілей.
Питання членства України в НАТО
так і не стало головним на порядку денному, хоча українська сторона
усіляко намагалась це зробити.
Байден обмежився загальним формулюванням:
Сполучені Штати й надалі рішуче підтримують суверенітет
та територіальну цілісність України з огляду на російську агресію,
а також євроатлантичні прагнення України.
Підтримка є, а термінів немає - так Зеленський підсумував слова Байдена
про плани України отримати членство у НАТО.
Водночас український президент запропонував США нові формати участі
у врегулюванні конфлікту на Донбасі.
Зеленський сказав, що хотів би участі Вашингтона - на рівні глави держави.
У Білому Домі цю пропозицію ніяк не прокоментували,
пообіцявши подумати. Окрім того, Зеленський публічно попросив
у Байдена допомоги у звільненні полонених на Донбасі.
Ми зранку передали вашій команді
список всіх полонених,
списки людей,  які перебувають на тимчасово окупованих територіях Донбасу,
в тимчасово окупованому Криму, в Росії.
І їх близько 450 людей.
Яку роль, яку допомогу можуть зробити Сполучені Штати?
Загалом до кінця 2021 року
США планують виділити України майже півмільярда доларів допомоги.
Натомість у Вашингтоні, хоча й похвалили Україну за прогрес у реформах,
вкотре наголосили на необхідності перетворення судової системи
і розбудові антикорупційної інфраструктури.